so um
let's proceed with that um
thank you uh i will try to be quite
brief because i know we are all tired
and this is the last talk of the day
but yeah i want to talk briefly about
how i'm using python as a framework for
doing analytics and growth hacking which
is a bit of a too long text it could be
the title of this tool could be as the
same yes
python as glue because it's basically
what i'm going to try to tell you
but uh more than than showing some
lines of code on on examples and running
some stuff which
i will also do at the at the end of the
talk i'm more interested into sharing
with you like a
mindset in general of how to do uh
analytics uh for for startups especially
in a business context but
could also be applied for larger
companies but
especially into the startup worlds and
how
uh analytics and data science uh can
can uh help a company growth
on and how python can be a good
environment to do that
so first of all i am ignacio lola a bit
of
about myself i have a i'm not a software
engineer
my background is in physics so i have
more fun stats and math
background than a developer background
uh
i write code that's like i was going to
say 100 of my day but it's
obviously not true 75 percent of my day
probably is writing code 25
talking about the code that i'm going to
write or scoping it which i guess is
natural um but yeah i've been
after studying physics i've been doing
some research on on
on the fields of systems biology and
then i've been
working lately as a data scientist in a
startup
called import io apart from all that
i am right now the man standing between
you
on german beer that we will have after
this so
i know it's a quite dangerous position
to win so i will try to be quick and to
make this
an enjoyable experience
import io is the startup where i'm
working at the moment
what we do is uh just for context
it is a platform and a tool to do
basically web scraping for people who
actually don't know what web scripting
is basically so people who don't have
coding skills can use our tool
to extract data from the web and create
apis even if they don't know they are
creating apis
you actually have some coding skills and
you know what an api is it's even better
because every time that you train
where the data is on a website we create
an api and then you can just use a rest
interface to interact with that
crawl entire sites or whatever and if
anybody is interested in talking more
about importeo after the talk
i will be around uh that's basically how
our browser
looks like let's go now with the tool
what is growth and it's not the tricky
question
it's not like kind of a trick your
question here is really a question that
we need to
ask ourselves when we are going to try
to do either growth hacking or analytics
uh in any kind of context and it doesn't
have a unique answer
i'm not going to answer that now because
it depends a lot on the context
and the industry probably but we will
see some examples uh
later on about different kind of
how we can measure it because uh
one of the most important things before
we can start uh
we can only assess what we can measure
and that's something very very very
important
uh so we need to define probably what
growth means to us
in order to measure it in order to
identify what are the
kpis for that and how we can hack then
how we can
uh you know trick it into into improving
uh and understand how it works
and why i'm talking about growth and not
just analytics
uh this is still a bit introduction uh
well because things need to have a
purpose analytics by itself can mean
you know i take this data and do some
fancy plots and here you have and i can
tell you a very nice
story about it but it might not listen
to anything
uh i'm talking about growth because i
want this analytics i want uh
measurements to lift into into something
that we can measure to listen to
in this case into growth or something
else if you are doing
analytics or you are doing data science
and
uh your analysis don't lead into
real actions either for you for somebody
else in the company
you're doing something wrong that's uh
that's my opinion or or how i see
things and so that's what i'm talking
about growth this needs to listen to
your business your company or the aspect
that you try to measure
growing or improving and why python i'm
not going to answer that
now i will answer it at the end
we will see then the the pros and cons
of using python for this kind of stuff
first of all i always like to show
this kind of stuff and i show it in a
lot of different contexts and it always
work
that's what i love that stuff because
you can use it for anything
the heroes journey uh i used to describe
what is the journey to to do data
science or to do analytics a lot of
times but i could use it probably to
most cases for what software development
is or especially software development on
an
agile or a lean environment
that's just the hero's journey on a
let's say
noble film video game context but it
works pretty well
i'm here correlating what they call call
to adventure with the parental solve or
the business question because that needs
to be the starting
point to any kind of analysis uh
we always have then the data collection
and data cleaning uh
process we have some exploratory data
analysis what we actually have here what
we think we can do with it
which after came what it's called in the
hero's journey
the revelation right there it's usually
when when the hero like died
by then it's revered uh that's when we
can
use algorithms and machine learning
there is there we could have a
discussion actually we can put
algorithms and material learning before
but i don't think it's that way because
you can only start uh
to apply some material into something if
you actually have a very clear idea what
you're going to do machine learning will
not tell you what to do
usually will give you very concrete
answers to very concrete questions
uh and then you just build your mvp from
there or you gotta have your answers
from your business programs and there
you're back into the loop
because you probably need to gather some
feedback review what you have learned
and probably start all over again or or
just you know improving what you have to
start that's why
it is a cycle
so this is what i start talking about
for anything here we need data and we
need to transfer that
into actions we need to transform that
into something that will change
something
basically and that data could mean
anything
that data could mean the data that you
have uh
in your platform it could be log files
it could be just
you know the data in google analytics
about what people is doing in your
website or or your application
or or data that you gather from the
internet or from some open source data
set about
whatever um
we need to get data and we need to use
data
that's the basic thing uh getting data
and putting some examples things of of
places where we can get data uh normally
so then i can build some examples on top
of
of this of this stuff uh
commonly google analytics whoa the
colors are terrible that was true
but you can you can probably uh in mind
what is there
google analytics everybody use google
analytics to one
degree or other uh might be just
your marketing team seeing what you know
how many visitors do you have
but you can do way more complex stuff in
google analytics
um mixpanel will be like up
and sorry to say this mixed manner could
be like a complex version of google
analytics where you can like just track
more stuff to uh
with a more granularity with with a
different degree
uh user voice or sendes which are
applications that
people use to do customer support or
user support very
you you can have an amazing source of
information
uh just there and both of them have apis
where you can just
grab everything and then use it for
other things salesforce the same
i will talk later more about salesforce
because
uh i don't know if you guys and if you
know what salesforce is at all
is what usually uh yeah it's like a crm
that sales guys use to sell things okay
so that's what it's called salesforce
huge company
but it has an amazing technology and you
can use it for
many more things that just to do cells
just cells is interesting enough because
if we are talking about
measuring growth and hacking growth you
can use that api and see hey how many
leads i have every month how many
uh i don't know what is my monthly
revenue
and i don't know a lot of patterns and
you can even try to to get the smarter
there and
improve things but apart from that it's
a very it's a crazy platform where you
can build
other things on top of it and then i use
just like a
cloud database uh icon to
to represent what could be two things
either
your internal database or platform of
your opera of your application or of
your company
like really what things are happening
there are sometimes you're recording
stuff
yourself on a database or or on on some
servers
or also the internet by itself which is
an a very good
source of information for for some use
cases
using data we could have very similar
services or or third-parties
libraries that we want to use uh excel
being an
amazing one on and it's an excel is an
amazing one because in excel you can
basically do
anything that you want excel can be used
as a front-end for
for uh for your database for your
aggregators of analytics
kpis and everything why because people
understand
excel everybody can use excel the ceo of
your company can use excel
your your business manager can you
sexual your marketing guy also you know
you cannot give them
sometimes well to some of these guys you
might give them you know this this
tableau connection to this crazy stuff
or or even something more complex and
some of them might be fine but not all
of them but all of them will be fine
with excel
so we need always to to
to have csvs in mind gekkoworth
building boards of metrics that's
amazing
things like mailchimp it's it's an
amazing hiking tool because you can just
create
i've been more in contact with mandar
than mention but i think you
basically can do mailchimp right now
everything that you used to be
able to do mandrill you can just you
know
do your own behavioral marketing emails
campaigns
uh on the go on the fly and that has an
api so you can do all that in python and
it's pretty cool
and i put salesforce in getting data and
using data
and i don't want to spoil anything i
will talk about it later
and of course i put like a chat a chart
um icon to represent
what is your custom reporting charts
or also modeling modeling and
predictions which
can be custom things that can just lead
into that
into like a chart or a custom report or
even better been integrated in some of
these tools that i'm putting
here and i'm putting just some stuff as
examples that i think
are a bit different one from each other
so can represent something but
obviously it's not a comprehensive list
so data to action data to action to me
looks something like this
uh why why python is great is because
uh you can interact with all these
things through apis
and then use all the data aggregate it
uh even build models or do some kind of
analysis and prediction on it
and then use all those other tools to
use that data and do something
meaningful with it
uh i put like
hard drive sign symbol on top of python
because in a lot of implementation a lot
of people i've seen this and i've done
this in the past you can have
a data warehouse in the middle of this
process where you are actually storing
aggregations of data or metrics and
depending on the case
that might be a very good idea or not we
can
chat about it later and i put a
third arrow very bad robot
connecting uh the first bit of the data
structure or the data gathering
and the data usage because uh we need to
keep an open mind about this and not be
obsessed about the tools that we use
that because we love python because we
love this kind of pipeline and we have
built this
now we are going to pass everything
through that thing because
sometimes it's not necessary a good
example is for example geckobot in
geckoboard you can
you can if you want to put
uh to do a dashboard with metrics that
came from your platform you need to you
to use the rest api and python is a
great way to do that
you schedule a job and then you have an
amazing dashboard there
but if you're going to put just metrics
that came from places like google
analytics or salesforce they have
their integrations they have done it for
you and it will work better than you
than what you will do so you just need
to press couple of buttons put
put an api token and it will work for
you so
keep always an open mind of what the
tools available are for those jobs
because sometimes
there are there are easy ways to do
stuff
um one example that i told briefly
uh it's about for example a kpi sheet a
performance indicator uh spreadsheet
that that we might
want to use to be reporting on on on
these
growth uh growth measures and growth
measurements
um one case normally
you have data coming from different uh
sources you can
you have data coming from google
analytics salesforce for example about
your your sales or something like that
and your platform
what people is doing in your platform
how many signups do you have
or how many uh usage is having and how
and uh python is great because you can
then
just using apis and maybe queries to
your own database
gather all together and and have unique
scripts
or unique set of scripts and modules uh
which is what i
what i built to write that and then use
that
in two different places and if you have
something unique to always gather this
data then you can say okay now i deci i
decide that i'm going to
i know gather a lot of data to do a
model or i'm just
gathering the data uh and doing a
summary of the last month
and i'm putting that as a row in the
spread in a spreadsheet and the code
that i put just there is
just doing exactly that you just gather
some data uh
not in the code apart and with that
those three lines you just
for example write a new line on a
spreadsheet
another example uh is is salesforce
that's this is what i wanted to talk
about uh salesforce
is salesforce has basically
uh some kind of relational database
uh underneath which is actually not a
relational database but
we could think about it as it is because
it's very similar
uh they don't disclose exactly how
the technology works so it's hard to
explain but
it's an oracle database exactly but but
they don't they don't
they don't define exactly how are all
the the the things on it so it's
a bit hard to to to explain it uh
but yes
they started like that but they have
something
way more complex right now with
force.com and with other things on top
of it
um the way i the way i like to use it is
um there is something that apart for for
from what is called like the sales sales
uh
the sales application which is the
normal things that people and the sales
guys use which have like
they have things that they call objects
which are basically like tables so we
can think about them as tables
and are like leads
your leads your accounts your
opportunities your i don't know what
contacts whatever and those are related
between each other
and that's great but you can build your
custom tables with your custom objects
and things on that
and the great thing is that if you build
one of those custom apps it's even
cheaper to subscribe to that
for your organization that than the
default sales
uh salesforce hasino is its own
programming language more or less to do
this kind of things which is apex
and i have used only like very few lines
but they have an api so you can
basically build everything else through
an api which is not the
uh better the best implementation but
it's the most convenient
one for some uh things so for example on
salesforce i built
a whole a whole screenshot let's say
of of of aggregations of data of
what is happening in import in import io
right now so i have an
object called users it's basically a
table of users with a lot of attributes
and for example there i'm doing a couple
of queries in python one two
i know to gather all the users but and
the second one is like to create a new
user and i put and i can put a lot of
custom
fields that i created like you know what
is the date of your last
login how many queries per day do you do
in the platform how many
uh pages you have convert using crawlers
and and things like that uh the amazing
thing is that when you have that kind of
thing you can put many other objects on
top of it and then you can start to
to build fan automate pipeline for
things you know
you can have things like i can have
labels and say
these are my active users these are my
very active users or something like that
and when
when a guy don't grave or upgrave uh i
can do something
i can i can fire from there uh i don't
know
a message to my support people
or a message to or a message directly to
some of those guys or things like that
so i can i can do
something i can take some action
in base of what is happening um
and that's pretty interesting a couple
of more things that i wanted to to show
and this is a bit following the the lean
analytics
methodology or or or track
i wanted to give one example on
on how to do a classic uh
growth hacking and acquisition and and
then
some some analysis and engagement and
hacking acquisition i want to do
something more generic so
this is something that i've seen apply
to a lot of different things i've seen
that happening in puerto rio shortly
more as a demo than anything
but i've seen also people doing this
especially for like
boost the the usage of apps or or
any kind of services uh what we can do
is we need to a way to do this is you
need
you in mind you ha uh you're building an
app
and you're launching the tap i don't
know next week or whatever
you're very interested in gathering at
least a few i don't know 1000 users from
the very beginning to get some virality
and timing there is very very important
you need
you need to do that on a very short
period of time
um if we are in the case of an app for
example
it's very important to gather like
reviews
very quick and more or less good reviews
because then even if you don't have a
lot of users a lot of
or a lot of installs you can ha you can
be promoted into like the
the i don't know the top things on the
iphone app store or something like that
and that will really give you a lot of
users
um and people do this all the time what
you do is
you may either identify potential users
online or
in the case of an app reviewers so you
can go to youtube
and check for uh app reviewers you
scrape the whole listing youtube for all
the people who do
app reviews and then you need to create
a way
for them to engage with you which might
be
we don't want to spam those people
because then you are you are you are
deaf
and and that there's no point on it you
need to actually do something more
meaningful and the way i've seen people
for example do this
is i can scrape all the youtube oh sorry
from from the youtube profiles for
example of all the app
reviewers uh i gather the most important
ones the ones that i
see they are having the biggest impact
and
i get their their twitter profiles and i
just use
one of these marketing tools which i
don't remember the name but you can just
google it
to to send private messages to all those
guys like follow
all those guys and send them private
messages or start a conversation with
all those guys and trying to engage
most of those people do that for a
living so if you pay them some money
they will do a review for you
that that doesn't mean that it's going
to be good or bad it depends if your app
is good or bad but most of the people
actually
receive money to do the the review
but this is a great thing if you are
sure you have a good app you pay a bit
of money you just
gather the the first the best 100
reviewers
in youtube and with a very small budget
you could have
i don't know maybe 20 30 40 reviews
in the first 24 hours which will uh uh
put you on on on a very good position on
the app store and give you really
thousands of
users you can then automate the process
and i put the
icon for robot because i like it but we
actually should try to be
as human as possible and as less robot
as possible because that is that is when
you screw the process if you actually
look like a robot
and you start basically spamming people
in this kind of automation process
which is is possible but
i mean everybody does in the same way
but you can do it very good or very bad
and when airbnb send you a behavioral
email they usually maybe
do it quite well because they have a lot
of
different emails for different
situations and they are missing it that
good and
maybe other people doesn't do it so good
and looks like spam and you mark that
spam
and there is no real benefit from them
and neither from you
um engagement
let's talk for example about engagement
engagement
i think i wanted to talk at the end
about these two things acquisition and
engagement because i think there are
like keys for any growth in any company
i found them as a
key metrics for for growth in any kind
of company
at a very different maybe moments you
know maybe when you're starting
you are more looking at the acquisition
which is like the top funnel
and and when you are more mature you
will
be looking more about engagement you can
still put a lot of people
in in your acquisition but if you're if
if your engagement is is is bad your
funnel is a screw and you will always
end up with
very few users at the end nobody wants
that
um so i've built a small model to
try to understand user usage doing a
cluster analysis
i think i need to go out now from here
and we can try to look at it live
if i find it um
let me check this is the right one yeah
so this is actual data of usage in
import io i yes i think
take out all indications of what some
parameters mean so it's
not too much explicit but
it's real data basically
and we can run this together
not going to explain everything because
it's
super simple code i'm just using
pandas and i'm using skype learn to
to do some clusters let's load thin
let's load this and i'm not going to run
min
shift let's just do comments
so here we just loath our model so we
sorry build the model with the data that
we load previously in pandas
and here we can just do the clusters and
plot them and what we have here the data
that i have here is just two dimensions
so it's
super simple just to try to see if we
can actually do something super simple
with just two dimensions with our
um volume and volume and frequency of
usage
with volume i mean in this case how many
uh making making it simple how many api
scales you are doing to the platform
because you can be doing that really
with a script
uh doing api calls or via an interface
but it doesn't matter
how many api calls are you doing to to
the imported platform
uh which is the let me think about
which which one of the two access it is
uh which is the one in the bottom i
think
and the one or the other way around
probably
and the other one is is uh
is frequency how many days you use us
for
so how many days you use import io for
the total number of days that you have
signed up and as you see uh
this is completely nonsense because
this the clusters the time that i'm
painting painting here are just bands
are just bounced by the frequency so
sorry by the volume so if you have done
much more volume
you suddenly got uh this cluster and
this other one and that one so it's only
uh it's only obeying one of the two
dimensions that i'm
that i'm plotting here and this
anybody knows why that is happening
something quite simple but i actually
happen all the time
does anybody have a clue
because you haven't normalized them
exactly
exactly because the dimensions are
complete are not normalized so they they
are completely
one it was from like from zero to one or
something like that and the other it was
thousands so then uh
the model cannot work properly because
it will
the weights are not are not correct if
we actually
uh change the dimensions we have
something that is much more
meaningful
oh just because i have another file
where i've done it before so i'm not
doing it
did you have a normalization yes yes yes
i've you i have a normalization script
basically
and the clusters that we have here are
basically you know we have uh this blue
cluster over here yeah you can see my
cursor
is basically people who have done very
little queries
on on and have a frequency of usage very
little so half users for
for uh just maybe a day or a few days
and then and then stop using us and and
some of these clusters are obvious so
i'm not learning anything from them like
that one for example but there are
others that are not so obvious
and especially the ones
over here or the ones or the ones over
here
are not so obvious which is uh people
maybe who use
who are doing a lot of volume in queries
so they have a lot of usage in that
sense but maybe less frequency
which in this case uh if we know with
the platform
it's it's people who are using crawlers
people who use scrollers especially
are not very technical and do that
through the ui it's people who can do
one million queries one day
and then not do any usage at all for the
last for the next month
uh and that's great because this this
silly model uh these cd clusters are
uh telling us already one thing that we
well we could have done the clusters
ourselves but we
we can identify um
a few a feature usage by just
plotting and doing a cluster between
usage and frequency
and that's great because if we just have
a couple of more dimensions we probably
can discover
another thing and because if we have
something like this
and we tweak it enough to be good enough
for let's say a production environment
we can use this kind of labels in i
don't know in my salesforce application
for example that i told before
or even on a user voice plugin which
means that
when a guy is answering a support ticket
can say hey this guy is actually a user
of this and these things
or is going to be a user of this and
these features
so i can i can give there a much better
support and that that's a
a real a real improvement in the
experience both both for the that user
that is going to do
in this hypothetical case a call to
support or an email to support and also
for the support guy who is answering it
because it knows much more about it
or or what the needs could be and can
can give
much better uh much better support
and do better job um
why python well especially now we can
see especially why python is good for
this because
if we want to do a bit of everything and
we are not only focused on doing
analysis and doing visualizations but
especially we are very interested in
communicating between different apis
and and and gathering data from one
place and putting in another
doing some things in in between those
kind of it those kind of
etls where you're communicating with
with web apis python is great for doing
that kind of stuff
um now upsides of it
it requires zero to liter data warehouse
to this kind of
stuff usually it's very very flexible
and and the speed to
just do one of these small hacks or to
do you know a small with you to do
something of that is
almost nothing you can do it in in a few
hours uh the downsize
is also that have zero to little data
warehouse so if you actually
don't plan this or don't design this
correctly then you can find that you are
either losing data or that you are
actually generating aggregate
data you need to store and then you end
up with a third
leg over there of a data warehouse
system that you don't know very with
what to do with it and then dependency
of apis it's actually
very nice to use apis to do all of this
work and to rely on them
but then you can have always uh if one
of the things
stop working then you are actually a bit
uh screwed happen
as an anecdote it happened to me just
this week
that um google deprecate
uh some of the some of their apis in the
data library which they actually
deprecated like three years ago but i
didn't know about it because they were
still working
so suddenly they really cut the cable
without
alerting anybody and me and a lot of
other people were like oh
my whole thing doesn't work now and i
need to write it from scratch again
but uh i don't think it's a very big
downside because usually it's
not such a a big effort and that's
everything thanks for the attention and
i'm open to
any questions both now and later
over there
any questions i know i know but
but maybe somebody has a like a really
deep question that cannot be answered
later with beer and need to
you know need to make it now you can
guys uh that's on the end of the
conference um
thanks for joining me thanks for having
me this is a great conference
great experience um you can join us
right here
downstairs
cool thank you
you